sa fille jane fiancée à l'école ah oui
quand elle s'appelait mais je crois que
ma femme ma première femme que j'ai
rencontrée en troisième en scène quand
elle s'appelait valérie valérie d'itella
valérie est en retrait en troisième on
jure c'est vrai alors 3e adéquat et
encore tu es tu dois demander en mariage
comment ben je vais demander en mariage
avec une tronche sur la frustration
à 22 ans on était on était la même fac
on s'en
fout ça vous avez une chance et bon à
l'école j'avais beaucoup de mal à
l'époque
est en fait j'avais repéré une jeune
femme qui était dans un autre cursus que
j'appelais dans ma tête obsession et
donc je la suivais partout quand il
rentrait chez elle
m'a dit si vous n'arrêtez pas monsieur
j'appelle la police
la da da dam qui donne 50 ans après doit
donner sa danse et des rats il me faut
encore faire un nom mais c'est calme toi
s'il te plaît calme-toi moi c'est une
histoire triste aime pas oui je vais pas
casser l'ambiance vigueur manière très
amoureux qu'on voulait
je l'avais écrit dans mon livre ah ouais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
t'emmerde pas avec ça on à l'antenne on
en dirait qu est ce que tu t'en fous on
se dépanne est une histoire assez
je sortais avec une jeune fille que sap
et patricia son père était patron des
douanes moi bon moi fils de gens
modestes je suis partie au château chez
eux pour son anniversaire à elle faisait
rage à tous oui c'est sûr ah oui à
gauche à touba bordeaux il ya beaucoup
ça tourne mal et moi je suis arrivé j'ai
planqué mon solex et dans la forêt à
côté j'arrive à pied et je voyais tous
les copains parce que c'était une bonne
école qu arriver avec les chauffeurs ou
même avec leur propre voiture tu vois le
truc moi je planque le solex déjà le
soleil qui fument et était sous le
soleil ce matin c'est une veste et où
enfin bon j'arrive très bien genre je
sonne à la porte du château il ya un
monsieur en gants blancs mais ça y est
c'est fini dit inquiète jeu super bien
mais c'est donc l'heure qu'il est et il
me dit vous n'êtes pas sur la liste
c'était ma chance et chante avec elle et
la dame il joue à une dame arrivée
magnifique franchement tuer le rêve un
peu c'était un beau château et elle me
dit non je sais que n'êtes pas sur la
liste et je regrette vous fréquentiez ma
fille ont fermé la porte je vous prie
que c'est le geste
alors je suis rentré les complexes que
je croise il dit mais tu vas où je
remonte dans le solex je pleure je serai
maison je tombe non je déchire la messe
les
parties
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
des cabanes il était sous le soleil oui
mais je me suis cachée derrière
l'immeuble chez moi on a lâché m à
bègles j'ai caché je me suis caché
jusqu'à la fin de la soirée
bah ouais c'était bien et j'ai raconté
une histoire ma mère s'est bien rattrapé
dans les soirées c'est pour ça que moi
bernard montiel il ya des matches où
même le président il fait une soirée il
est remonté le bordel de merde bah ouais
les gars mais bon j'apprends de mes
fonctions bas mais bartoli qui se passe
bordel de merde voilà bomba très belle
histoire
vous à venir un vous aviez alors ça va
nous avions d'amoureux à l'école mais
jamais si le match est prof de maths
aujourd'hui
il est mort il ya trois quatre ans il
part oui ça on est obligées si j'étais
un peu comme perso je les suis
c'est monsieur corse on aurait dit un
peu gainsbourg il était un peu crado
chez huawei moi j'aime et benjamin
genton
elle aime quand ces salles elle
paraissait wells et la madame si tu
prends du sexe
je peux te dire je nettoie tout du sol
au plafond
mais la maison 600 a vu ses glandes
[Applaudissements]
l'enjeu ramasser ses craies j'avais
c'était complètement les doulas
comment au niveau des calculs
j'avais des gros problèmes
psychologiques lait de la crème
antoine huis clos il s'en foutait du
nord il s'en fout après t'as pas eu un
petit copain même à l'école et non après
je suis passé à jean-moulin fin des
violences en tant qu ici c'est un
vecteur
chocolat
avec j'étais amoureuse comme il est
sorti avec moi
[Rires]
koné st jean le poulain n'était pas beau
c'était bon ça va ça mais je touchais
chauve a
rien dit j'ai un ami à moi il est petit
gros il est très beau gosse non mais le
charme et c'est le charme agir axes non
mais c'est vrai donc après lui après
deux jours donc jouer à tricoter paradis
pousser quoi
je vais tricoter une écharpe j'ai vu
qu'il était un mythe il ya un film où il
ya mon écharpe
tricotée à merveille même agité que
comateux loin une vie triste
très légèrement avec s'appelle jean le
poulain on les connaît c'est quoi c'est
un battant il est vrai qu'après c'est
quoi tu sais qui tu as pris ton 1er mai
qui s'appelait comment alors ben ça non
mais ça va nous aider alors maintenant
prénom c'est direct c'est à dire j'ai
pas draguer tout de suite est un vecteur
bof
c'est bon dialogue et sur un arbre
[Applaudissements]
guatemala guatemala non juste avec le
bien de l'enfant
[Rires]
ces gens le poste
mais gâche rien n'était dont elle
a développé un talent
mais c'est un truc
de ouf on chez un bon film bravo à tmz
pourquoi basques à la maison toujours de
brûlures
tél
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ils étaient partagés
juge pression pour trouver l'image de
jean le poulain avec les chapes la
bbc moi je m'y attendais pas
gps écran à te faire pleurer en abattant
le coup là aussi papy brossard
enfin j'étais veuf plein de fois parce
que comme j'étais amoureuse n'est pas
assez bon mais très dense mais la merci
parce que je le dis et vous a déjà en q1
jean le poulain de photos en fait
j'étais dans une cabine téléphonique en
face de chez lui
je passais des après midis chez moi il
ya une âme une vieille dame
tu
[Applaudissements]
as quelque chose
il s'achevait hier la thur à dire
respecte bien sûr moi je trouve très
beau c'est un énorme honneur à différer
la chevalière des ménages chevalière
comme ça et puis le doigt le petit doigt
un peu un peu plus long pour jouer de la
guitare
[Rires]
[Musique]
je suis jeune et je la trouve son
dégoût disais ouais quand on était
gosses tout l'écho l'eau tiède
sénégalais